public health experts say that Kovan 19
is extremely dangerous unless you are
protesting systemic racism major cities
across America prepare to defund police
after nationwide rioting in institutions
from sports to the media cast out the
unwelcome ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the venture Pierrot show is sponsored by
expressvpn my savvy fans secure their
internet join them expressvpn comm slash
pen well I told you not to burn down the
country over the weekend and you didn't
burn down the country so much as
destroyed all of its fundamental
institutions so it's really interesting
to watch as all of America's fundamental
institutions come under severe assault
everything from our government
institutions to the media to sports I
spent the weekend trying to think how
can you escape from all of this and the
answer is you really can't because the
truth is if you turn on a football game
these days you are likely to get a
lecture from Colin Kaepernick and why
the American flag is bad and if you turn
on a basketball game you're likely to
hear some commentators talking about how
LeBron James school drew brees and if
you try to turn on Amazon Prime and just
watch a movie you're gonna get a
blacklivesmatter banner and a bunch of
movies they recommend about this
particular topic hey listen everybody is
entitled to their opinion but let's just
be frank about what is going on right
now what is going on right now is a
nationwide push by all of your major
institutions to suggest that America is
systemically racist and that you as a
white person bear some guilt for that
and if you're a person of color you
don't but it depends I mean do you agree
with the American Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence that these
are good ideas if you do then you are
part of the problem as well everybody
ought to kneel together we all ought to
kneel together in order to recognize
that America is systemically racist and
this is expected from people right and
left and center is it is expected from
everyone this is the message that is
being promulgated we're gonna get to the
message and we're gonna get to the evils
of that message because I cannot think
of a less unifying message then America
is systemically racist and evil and one
group of people is deliberately
responsible for that and even if you
aren't responsible for anything bad you
are responsible for that bad thing it's
amazing how fast we turn from police
brutality is bad a proposition that 100%
of Americans agree with to America is
systemically racist and evil and also
get rid of the police and you have to
think that there is a certain math to
this on the part of the left because the
truth is that when you get down to the
brass tacks of what kind of policies
will be likely to mitigate police
brutality there's fairly broad agreement
things like curbing police unions for
example and and qualifying qualified
immunity right scaling back qualified
immunity you go back to sort of the
common law standard as opposed to the
Supreme Court
standard implemented in 1982 there's
fairly broad approval for a lot of these
measures but as per our usual political
conversation everyone shied away it
seems from the discussion of the actual
measures to be undertaken in order to
mitigate the problem in order to create
conflict around a bigger idea people
want to talk about the quote unquote
bigger idea they don't want to talk
about solving the problem which suggests
they're really not interested in solving
the problem they're really interested in
the broader idea which is remaking
America on the back of a simple
assumption all inequality is inequity
all inequality is the result of systemic
racism systemic racism can never be
cured inequality can never be cured and
thus the Utopia must be consistently
sought and that is the message of
today's politics it's a religious
message as I mentioned last week the
message of today's politics is that you
will never be able to reach utopia
because the inequality will always exist
and we will always attribute inequality
to the evils of the system we're gonna
get to what happened over the weekend
because it truly is astonishing in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that your cell phone bill it
probably is not going down right now
probably spending an awful lot of time
on your phone but are you really using
all of your data the truth is you should
be paying a fraction of what you are
currently paying to yourself your cell
phone provider instead you should be
switching to pure talk USA you can cut
costs and free up cash on a monthly
basis starting with your wireless
provider peer talk covers 99% of
Americans the president and CEO of care
talk is u.s. veteran who cares deeply
about serving Americans by making
wireless affordable
start you're saving today dial palan 250
say keyword ben shapiro for unlimited
talk unlimited text and 2 gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month plus you'll
get 50% off your first month which is a
great deal it's probably you know
one-fifth of what you are paying 1/10 of
what you are paying right now again
you're not using more than 2 gigs of
data and all likelihood anyway so you're
just paying for all of that unlimited
data that you're not actually using
instead stop paying too much too big
wireless providers and switch to pure
talk today save 50% off your first month
now pound 250 say the keyword ben
shapiro pure talk USA simply smarter
Wireless same quality coverage you're
getting from all the other carriers and
you're getting it a lot cheaper they
bound to 50 and say the key word ben
shapiro to join pure talk USA now pound
to 50 say key word ben shapiro ok so let
us begin with the first religious for
the first sort of religious
cry from the left that religious cry is
that apparently a vaccine has been
developed for coven 19 and that vaccine
is systemic anti-racism right aunt I
woke ISM is not a mind virus woke ISM is
the vaccine the vaccine was in our
hearts all along guys it was in our
hearts all along so all the people who
were protesting and they were saying I
want to go back to my job because I've
lost my livelihood and I want my kids to
go back to school because they need to
be in school they're losing months off
of their educational career here all the
people who said I want to go back to
church because the center of my life is
the church those people were told over
and over and over again they were
killing grandmother they're told over
and over again you cannot go back to
these places because if you do you will
move you're responsible for spreading
the virus you will kill hundreds of
thousands of Americans if you do this
thing over the weekend literally
millions of Americans were out in the
streets millions of them
crowding on top of each other right out
shouting screaming as dr. Marty Meharry
from Johns Hopkins University told me
last Friday there is there there it is
hard to think of a better vector for
virus spread than the sorts of images
that we saw over the weekend you saw
these huge shots of Philadelphia streets
and streets teeming with people no masks
if they do have masks that are moving
them from time to time so they can shout
slogans right up on top of each other
right next to each other people have
said that churches are great vector for
virus transmission because you are in a
small area with a lot of people singing
or yet or yelling or shouting or talking
okay these protests are a great virus
transmission vector they are but not
according to other health experts our
health experts say it is more important
that you protest then that you try to
minimize the spread of kovin 19 which is
amazing because for months we destroyed
40 million jobs in this economy
40 million jobs which is tens of
millions of lives destroyed by the way
we destroyed those jobs and the
attendant lives that are dependent on
those jobs including the lives of
children we destroyed all of those
because we were so convinced that
preventing the spread of Kovach 19 was
that important now as long as you're
shouting the right slogans it's totally
fine dr. Tom Fernan who's the former CDC
director under Barack Obama he tweeted
out the threat to kovat control from
protesting outside his tiny compared to
the threat to kovat control created when
governments act in ways that lose
community trust people can protest
peacefully and work together to stop
coalbed violence harms public health ok
let's be straight about this according
to the
latest Washington Post statistics and
they keep updating the numbers there
were grand total of 15 black men shot
horn on Horan armed last year we've had
over a hundred and ten thousand deaths
in the United States in the last three
and a half months alone from Cove in
nineteen so I'm gonna go no on it's more
of a systemic threat to public health
the police
broadly speaking then the then the
protests were yesterday in fact I can
say that with an extraordinary degree of
certainty that that is not the case so
long as you believe that Cove in
nineteen is actually dangerous dangerous
which I do but apparently the CDC
experts do not examined enough to
remember when Tom Ford and was on
national TV suggesting that Rhonda
census was gonna kill everybody because
Ron De Santis wasn't shutting the
beaches of Jacksonville which by the way
killed nobody so it turns out that woke
ism is the virus it's the vaccine virus
it's amazing we should give Colin
Kapernick the Nobel Peace Prize for
apparently ending racism because
kneeling as we will see ends racism and
not only should we give him the Nobel
Peace Prize we should give him the Nobel
Prize in biology because it turns out
that kneeling also stops Kovan 19 it's
incredible what can't kneeling do it's
unbelievable
there are pictures of health care
workers you remember all those pictures
from the anti lockdown protests of
health care workers standing outside
arms crossed very stern mask over face
your Runa you're ruining our lives
you're making our lives more difficult
stay home to keep us safe health care
workers were out there taking a knee in
the middle of protests in New York City
yesterday
okay so let's either they were lying
then or they are lying now
if they're lying there's no two ways
about it either they were lying about
the danger of the virus in which case
the lockdown was completely ridiculous
and there was no reason for it or
alternatively there rightly cautious
about the virus and they are lying now
when they suggest that it's perfectly
safe to go outside or at least the risk
of going outside and protesting on mass
about racism is less than the risk of
Kovan 19 all this looks like is
politically motivated trash not that not
the protests themselves the idea that
you can discard all concern about kovat
19 because you like the message of the
protest for by the way government actors
have been saying the sort of stuff it's
First Amendment violative obviously
violative of the First Amendment is a
content-based restriction there were
literally people saying you cannot liken
anti lockdown protests to protests on
behalf of George Floyd or against the
police or any of the rest of us
that's not how protesting works under
the First Amendment
guys you can't do that you can't say
we're shutting down the protest because
we don't like this message but we do
like this message so therefore the
threat doesn't exist any longer this is
insanity and by the way if you're
suggesting that all these protests are
deeply necessary and these protests are
are deeply important I have some
questions about dancing the Malka
Brendon with protesters I just do I just
do okay so we were told you can't be in
a hospital with your grandmother as she
dies because you might come out and
spread Kovan 19 to others we were told
you can't go to church and have a
funeral service for grandma after she
dies but we can have National Guard's
people doing the Macarena in the streets
with people who are protesting about
police brutality deeply necessary deeply
important work by the National Guard
right here with the protesters very very
important stuff this is what we pay our
tax dollars for I'm very excited about
all of this
now again you want to show that your
anti police brutality it seems to me
that everybody's anti police brutality
it's funny I spoke to a friend of mine
who is a police officer at a met
remaining a major city and he was on the
front lines yesterday he's been on the
front lines for 12 days straight no
brakes doing 14-hour shifts 12 14-hour
shifts and his partner has been attacked
with a brick got a concussion
he's been attacked with a knife he was
not injured thank God he was in one of
these protests and he went up to a
protest one of the protesters came up to
him and he said to the protester like
you understand that I think they're at
Shelvin the officer in the George Floyd
situation should be prosecuted I'm a
good cop he was a bad cop he should go
to jail and the pro stores like yeah we
understand they said well you understand
them my colleagues all agree with me and
they agree with you the derektrips so
what exactly are you protesting and the
guy said well you know we just think the
police are racist okay so how much of
this is absolute nonsense a lot of it
and I gotta say I think that a lot of
this is driven not by a desire to quote
unquote end police brutality which again
everybody agrees with but by the fact
that everybody's been pent up for three
months in their homes and now they're
gonna go out on mass and they're
basically going to engage in a party
when you see people dancing the Macarena
in the street that does not look like a
Martin Luther King jr. walk through
Selma that looks like people partying
because it is people partying when I see
people riding and looting that does not
look like an extension of justified rage
what that looks
his people partying rioting and looting
and if you watch the tape these are not
people with frowns on their face and
anger in their face these are people
excited that they just got to take a TV
in to pretend otherwise is to just lie
about the situation so if you are angry
at the system today and by the way if
you think that America is about to be
mugged by kovat reality you're probably
right because one or two things is gonna
happen
either there will be a giant spike in
Kovach cases in which case you were lied
to by all the health experts who told
you that it was okay to go out and
protest and then they will do this
routine where they say well you know the
protests were necessary so in the end it
wasn't us saying it's good to protest
that spread the virus it wasn't us
saying that sort of stuff
it was racism we saw this from the
health commissioner of New York City
five seconds ago saying if you go
outside they're gonna kill grandma
saying if a lot of people die from the
protests because of kovat 19 that's
because of racism
how convenient racism can be blame for
everything including your own massive
hypocrisy and stupidity but again this
is all about the broader message because
the only way you can really get to the
conclusion that it's okay to go out on
mass and protest in the middle of a
pandemic and by the way this the sort of
stuff was tried back during World War
one people have talked about the Spanish
flu as dr. Meharry said on my show last
week during the Spanish flu there were
these giant Liberty Bond rallies they
were one of the chief vectors for
transmission of the Spanish flu so we've
we've done this before gang and it
didn't go all that great but the only
way that you can make the argument that
from a public health standpoint it is
important to protest in the middle of a
pandemic is if you truly believe that
the American system is corrupt through
and through and that's really what this
argument has become about whether the
American system is corrupt through and
through from root to branch from
beginning to end and that is why people
are demanding that other people kneel
for things they have not done this is
why people are demanding people wash
feet for things they have not done and
the very idea of kneeling to atone for
us and you did not commit is sinful it
is sinful if you do not commit a sin and
you are kneeling to atone for that sin
that is a pagan istic ritual one of the
great discoveries of judeo-christian
religion is the idea that you are not
responsible for the sins of your parents
then in fact you are an individual who
is responsible to God and others for the
things that you do but the very idea
that you're supposed to kneel on behalf
of a system that you did not create and
do not like or alternative
that the system is to blame for all
inequality so you kneel on behalf of the
system what you're really doing is
you're not kneeling to take in your own
sin what you're really doing is you are
kneeling in order to indict others
you're really kneeling and virtually
signaling in order to invite people who
won't kneel and who don't believe the
system is evil in order to incite the
founders in order to incite people who
won't kneel for the flag that's really
what a lot of this is about and that's
immoral that's immoral if you are
kneeling the kneeling symbol is
incredibly vague if you're kneeling
because you are just attempting to
symbolize the the police brutality that
took George Floyd's life that is one
thing let's become much more than that
it has been linked to the Colin
Kaepernick kneeling it's been linked to
the idea that America's systemically
racist that is the message that is being
promulgated if you are kneeling to
suggest that America is evil then you're
doing something sinful because America
is not evil if you're if you're kneeling
to indict your fellow citizen as evil
for not believing that America is evil
that is also sinful if you are kneeling
to take upon yourself a sin that you did
not commit that is sinful because you're
an individual and every individual ought
to be answerable for his or her sins
they ought not be answerable for the
sins of other people because once you
start in with this idea that you are
responsible for the sins of everybody
else that's how you get to the brutality
of collective responsibility and that is
very nasty very quickly especially when
you're not talking about the the sort of
implications of wartime in which you
have no choice but to go after military
targets and sometimes there are
civilians that you're talking about just
in normal politics blaming large groups
of people for the actions of a few and
it's hard to think of anything worse
than that you take that to the racial
level and it's racism it is racism to
say okay well there are some people of
this race who do a bad thing there for
everybody of this race is sinful and
indicted that way you take it to any
other level it's just as sinful we're
gonna get to more of this message in
just one second because this is this is
the great battle this is the great
battle and you will see it has some very
practical ramifications because once you
indict the entire system you have to
tear out the system root and branch and
it doesn't matter how many lives that
cost particularly in the minority
community which is what's about to
happen and what we're about to watch is
gonna be so ugly it's gonna make your
head swim we're gonna get to that in
just one second from that dark message
do something more upbeat let's talk
about something great that you can do
for your dad this year for Father's Day
get him Tommy John Tommy John is the
revolutionary
underwear and clothing brand they know
that comfort is for everyone yep even
dad so give him the softest most
breathable base layer he has ever worn
there are new and improvements underwear
it's now twice as durable as his current
pair infinitely more luxurious
guaranteed Tommy Chunn underwear are
spectacular I know because they graced
my took us this very moment Tommy John
is offering their best Father's Day deal
ever 25% off site-wide
including easy to give sets that you can
order straight from your phone directly
to dad's door treat dad to a few pairs
of Tommy Khan underwear in the softest
most breathable fabrics he's ever worn
all the Tommy John's layers are built
for next level comfort whether you're on
the hunt for lounge pants or lazy day
lazy day joggers or the softest zoom
ready tees and polos you or your dad has
ever worn Tommy John has got you covered
I mean these are all amazing amazing
products this it's the most comfortable
stuff ever and how do we know because
they have a full refund with their best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee Tommy John is the perfect gift
for all the dads in your life deliver
comfort directly to dads store with 25%
off site-wide at Tommy John comm /ban
that is Tommy John comm slash spend 25%
off site-wide see site for details Tommy
chiming that's good stuff right there
okay so the broader message the broader
message here is that you can protest on
mass in the middle of a pandemic you can
do whatever you have to do because the
system itself is evil and the system
itself is racist and all inequality can
be laid at the feet of inequity now when
people talk about systemic racism they
always failed to define it so there are
a few ways you can define systemic
racism there are two ways that are
obviously untrue and one way that is
true okay so the two ways that are
obviously untrue all inequality is
inequity so anytime you see inequality
in American life that's because
something unfair and terrible has
happened that is not true it's simply
not true
some people make bad decisions and some
people don't make bad decisions some
people grew up in a better home and some
people grow up in a worse home this has
nothing to do with race this is just
true for every human being
not all inequality is inequity sometimes
people are born smart and sometimes
people are born stupid sometimes people
are born with more grit and sometimes
people are born with more of a tendency
toward toward lassitude right that there
there are plenty of differences among
human beings without regard to race hey
my siblings and I are not equivalent in
every way that does not mean some
inequity happen in our household it
means that people are born different and
people act differently and make
individual choices differently so if by
systemic racism you mean
that you can cite a statistic that
suggests that more black people are
arrested on a percentage basis than
white people and that this means that
the system is to blame that some
inequity has taken place you're gonna
have to explain what the inequity is
what is the policy inequity that is
happening right now
you can't just cite the disparity and
say discrimination has taken place
because that's not necessarily true
maybe it has maybe it hasn't systemic
racism is ghost-hunting in this context
it is the suggestion that even after you
take into account all of the various
other factors the only factor it's the
god of gaps the only factor we can't
explain it must be racism it must be
racism so for example there's this video
that's been going around that people
have been pushing around all about
systemic racism and it talks about
redlining and the impact of redlining
and then it cites a bunch of studies and
the studies that it cites include a
study from the 1992 Federal Reserve of
Boston talking about redlining and they
talked about the fact that black people
were unable to get home loans at the
same rate as white people it neglects to
mention that that same study found that
black owned banks were actually lending
at a lower rate to black owned
businesses than white owned businesses
maybe it doesn't have to do with racism
maybe it has to do with credit record
for example or a level of or level of
wealth that can be taken as collateral
right there are other factors that might
explain disparities the immediate jump
from inequality to inequity is not
correct all in all inequality is not
inequity so that that idea of systemic
racism is deeply damaging and an
incredibly counterproductive because it
doesn't suggest good policy it just
suggests inciting people for things that
you cannot evidence they've done the
second is that all current institutions
are racist in this you see from the 1619
project all institutions are infected
with racism now they make a bit of a
different argument which we'll get to in
a second the argument that today's
institutions in America are systemically
racist is just pure nonsense it's
illegal it's literally illegal in fact
the institutions in America that do
discriminate on the basis of race
typically discriminate in favor of black
Americans affirmative action
discriminates on behalf of black
Americans against asian-americans Jewish
Americans and white Americans that's
what it does okay that because they're
only a certain number of slots
that's a zero-sum game if you say that
certain people don't have to get the
same scores as other people that is
obviously discriminatory against the
people we now have to get the higher
scores there are there plenty of
scholarships available across the
country on a race-based preference
suggestion the notion that that policy
across the country is systemically
racist is just not true
so that today's institutions are not
racist and if you can incite a policy
that is racist let me know about it
because I'm happy to oppose it with you
okay then there's the third argument
about systemic racism and this is that
history has consequences
this is obviously true the history has
consequences but to say that history has
consequences does not mean that all
consequences are due to history right so
people are now mixing up is what the
16:19 project does they are mixing up
the first two bad arguments about
systemic racism with the third argument
which is obviously true history has
consequences because here's the thing
history has consequences for every group
but that does not define every group
that does not define the behavior of
every group history has consequences for
Jews it has consequences for Asians it
has consequences for Latinos and by the
way so does mistreatment personal
histories have consequences for people
but some of the question revolves around
how you react to bad things happening to
you in your life right when I was six
somebody called me a did
it ruin my life it did not few years ago
back in 2016 I was the number one target
of anti-semitism online did it ruin my
life it did not do I think America is
systemically racist I do not when my
wife was a kid she was walking down the
street with her father in Sacramento a
guy drove by threw a rock at her and
shouted kill the Jews did it ruin her
life
no it didn't so history has consequences
but so does human action so to say that
bad things happened in the past and thus
all inequality that is existent today is
due to the bad things that happen in the
past is to make a leap that's the leap
that people want you to make and want to
say because we can all acknowledge the
bad things happen in the past and so the
idea is that all bad things that happen
today are outgrowths to bad things that
happen in the past that is true but in
that chain that does not mean that that
is the proximate cause okay there are
many many intervening causes including
personal decision making if in fact the
wealth gap has grown between black and
white families in the aftermath of the
Civil Rights Act you have to explain why
you have to explain why it is that as
redlining Wayan redlining by the ways
may be legal in 1975 under the Community
Reinvestment Act if you if after the
Civil Rights Act the gap between white
and black got larger if the middle class
started growing slower after the Civil
Rights Act if in fact educational
disparities became larger after the
Civil Rights Act
if single motherhood went up after the
Civil Rights Act you have to explain why
exactly it was racism that drove all
that you can't just say history made it
this way you actually have to explain
what you have to explain the chain of
logic and then you have to explain what
you think the logical redress is we'll
get to the fact that nobody wants to
explain the logical redress because the
logical redress is bad policy and once
you suggest that everything is broken
down the only solution is to tear down
the system as a whole that's how you get
to defund the police we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that these days you need
sleep
I don't know about you but the between
the news and between my kids my amount
of sleep has dropped significantly I
mean radically my kids are getting me up
at all hours in the morning I'm staying
up late at night in order to prep for
the show and in order to deal with the
stress of the daily news cycle well that
means that when I lie down on that
mattress hitted damned well better be
comfortable and it is it is my helix
sleep mattress because it was made just
for me Hugh except as a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper or a hot sleeper
looking like a pleasure from bed with
helix there's no more confusion and no
more compromising helix sleep is rated
the number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on go to hulex leap comm slash been take
their two-minute sleeve quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
at risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you
definitely will I mean I speak from
personal experience it is fantastic
helix he's offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress workers right now for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off and
helix sleep comm slash Bennett's helix
sleep comm slash man go check them out
right now helix sleep comm slash man
again it's risk free and get 200 bucks
off helix leap comm slash Bennett
doesn't get better than then ok so again
the message that is being pushed here
and that we are all being told that we
must accept is that America is
systemically racist and the death of
George Floyd is somehow tied into this
now again you have yet to hear that that
Derek shavon is was motivated by racism
here we actually don't know that right
well all we know is that that was an
aspect of police brutality but we don't
know that this is about racism but again
it is everything bad must be a racist
thing and everything racist must be
attributed to Americans more broadly
particularly white Americans this is
gonna have some consequences when it
comes to policy because once you suggest
the entire system is root and branch
evil it has to be torn out by the root
and when you tear out the system by the
root you don't get to keep all the
benefits of the system while tearing out
the system by the root I know there are
a lot of Americans pretty
white liberals who tend to believe that
the natural state of things is an
orderly society in which people treat
each other well and rioting and looting
are not common and which crime is down
this is because you don't remember the
1960s I don't either but I can promise
you there are a lot of people who still
do in the 1960s it's particularly that
the late 1960s crime rates skyrocketed
because of a deliberate attempt to
reduce policing because of a deliberate
attempt to treat crime as a
manifestation of outrage at the system
you do that there gonna be some pretty
significant consequences
okay so ABC's Rachel Scott said
yesterday that George Floyd's death was
about centuries of systemic racism and
racial inequality again she's gonna have
to explain why it is not just about an
officer who committed an act of police
brutality that nearly every other
officer believes was enacted evil and
all Americans do here here was Rachel
Scott yesterday making any broad-based
argument the killing of George Floyd was
really just the boiling point this is
about centuries of systemic racism and
racial inequality that has existed in
this country and I think what we are
seeing right now is generational
exhaustion and generational uprising
these are young voices that are out
there from all different backgrounds
demanding for change and as we see
thousands of protesters out there it's
important to note that every single one
of them has a story either they have
experienced racism themselves some black
Americans asking themselves am i next
okay if you're asking yourself are you
next the answer is no the answer is by
all available evidence know that you're
not next to be the next George Floyd
because again we can name all the people
this has happened to I can't name all
the victims in Chicago over the weekend
there are over 20 of them but I can
certainly name the the people in the
last several years who have died at the
hands of police brutality the this
notion that again all bad things can be
laid at the feet of the system this is
about an argument that system ought to
be torn down
Val Demings who's being widely
considered a possible VP for Joe Biden
again she made the same point we've been
fighting institutional racism for 400
years does not define institutional
racism does not explain which policies
ought to be changed instead the ideas
that America has not changed since 1619
which is an insane contention is an
insane contention she's a sitting
congresswoman from Florida how many
blacks hitting Congress people from
Florida were there in 1619
okay what what are you talking about to
pretend that to say things like we've
been fighting institutional racism for
400 years as though there's been little
or no progress or as though we are even
remotely anywhere close to what we even
were in the 1960s is patently insane but
again if the argument is that you hate
the system and you want to tear it out
then you have to make the argument that
either the current system is fruit of
the poisonous tree which is the 16:19
project argument from the New York Times
or you have to make the argument that
the system itself has generated
inequality because it is today
institutionally racist here's Val
Demmings again Joe Biden my picker for
repeat making this argument look if
we're gonna solve some of America's
toughest problems we've got to be
painfully honest about what those
problems are and we know that we have
been fighting systemic racism in this
country for 400 years we know that it
has found its a reared its ugly heads
and law enforcement agencies and housing
and education and and too many other
places so it's everything it's all the
things it's all the things so a couple
of things that are just reality you
cannot fight history because history is
over you don't have a time machine you
can't do it if your suggestion is that
you can vitiated the problems of history
by engaging in in modern-day injustice
modern-day injustice is not going to
vitiate the problem it is simply going
to exacerbate other problems pursuing
policies that victimize some at the
behest of others is not good policy that
was the problem with the history so to
try and reverse the history by
suggesting discrimination in a different
form is not going to solve the problem
I'll tell you what else is not going to
solve the problem
teaching millions of Americans that no
matter how hard they try the system is
coming down on top of them there are no
American you can't name the Americans
who are in favor of what Derek Shelvin
did they don't exist if they do you're
talking about like seven guys truly if
the notion is that there's a cadre of
people who are just trying to keep black
people down who are these people so we
can fight them it's a conspiracy theory
when you go around suggesting that no
matter how you try I mean honestly I
cannot I can't I mean I never do this
but as a Jew
hey Jewish history has been replete with
some pretty significant repression I'm
talking about like
forcing people into it not just ghettos
in the American sense of bad places to
live where you can't afford to live out
of them I mean forced ghettos where Jews
were forced to live and they shut them
down at nightfall and you could not exit
on pain of imprisonment or death I'm
talking about the banning of Jews from
social institutions here in the United
States I'm talking about the fact that
Jews were banned from certain areas of
higher education for decades in the
United States okay that's in the United
States it's not even abroad abroad it's
way worse obviously I'm not even
mentioning the treatment of my extended
family in the Holocaust or anybody
else's and for generations Jews
recognize that life was a terrible thing
and that if you worked hard you were
still expected to do the things you were
supposed to do okay but in America in a
free country
Jews have risen extraordinarily quickly
why because there was no boot on their
neck overall despite all of those things
that I've mentioned there was no boot on
their neck and there is nothing more
damaging that you can tell a child than
no matter how hard you work you are
going to be put down no matter how hard
you work there is a there is a glass
ceiling there are people who are trying
to keep you down in America a free
country nobody is thinking enough about
you to try and keep you down no one
cares about you and I don't mean that
any people want to watch you suffer
sense I mean that nobody is sitting
around thinking how do I keep a black
person down today how do I create a
policy to prevents black people from
doing X Y or Z in fact everybody as far
as I'm aware has been thinking how do I
create policy that gives more
opportunities to people who are who have
grown up in poor communities with bad
educational systems like is such a
damaging message it's such a damaging
message if you want to damage an entire
generation of people tell them that they
are inherently victims in the free
society in the history of the world and
this way you get from Al Sharpton who's
made a bunch of money that is a dude who
has gotten rich off of this myth hey al
Sharpton has gotten rich off of lying to
people that America is systemically
racist and evil top to bottom he just
goes to corporations than blackmails
them by suggesting he will call them
racist unless they give him a donation
here he was at George Floyd's memorial
suggesting that no matter how hard we
try there's a knee on our necks that was
true in legal terms during Jim Crow
it was obviously true during slavery
it is not true today it has not been
true for at least a couple of decades
and I mean several decades America is
the story of black people fighting for
their freedom and white people fighting
alongside them to fulfill constitutional
declaration of independence ideals
that's the story of America if you're
telling a young black person in America
today that the system is out to get you
you are lying you are lying the system
is not out to get young black Americans
the system is trying to promote
everybody including young black
Americans and if you are a young black
American who's listening to the show
today and you're thinking to yourself
how do I get ahead the answer is you
make good decisions because people are
not standing in your way people want to
help you people want to help people to
malign Americans as part of the same
system that enslaved people is
disgusting it is but else Sharpton's are
disgusting human beings that's alright
here it was yesterday
over the weekend 101 years ago the
reason we could never be who we wanted
and dream to be in is you kept your knee
on our neck
we were smarter than the underfunded
schools you put us in but you had your
knee on our neck we could run
corporations and not hustle in the
street but you had your knee on our neck
and then he says get your knee off our
neck today ok again to equate Jim Crow
America with today is patently insane
but again if you are al Sharpton and you
are trying to equate all inequality with
inequity then this is what you have to
do where you blame the system more
broadly it's not just now sharp 10 who's
an open race baiter and an awful human
being
it's Michelle Obama who really should
know better this is a woman who went to
Harvard Law School this is the former
First Lady of the United States she's
had a pretty damn good life in the
United States but here she was giving a
speech to graduates over the weekend
suggesting that for many black Americans
no matter how hard you work structural
racism is stopping you please name the
policy that is stopping you no matter
how hard you work please tell me the
policies we can fight it together but
nobody ever suggested policy nobody ever
wants to talk about policy why because
that would mean you'd have to get
specific and then we might all have a
solution but if there's a solution then
inequality
might actually decline and if inequality
declined
then it might be that Americans aren't
racist again if you start from the
premise that all inequality means racism
and it is it is necessary for your
political point of view that the system
be racist and inequality must be
preserved any attempts to mitigate
policies such that inequality is not
preserved means maybe the system isn't
so bad and that runs counter to the
entire left-wing argument here's
Michelle Obama
one the most successful black women in
American history suggesting that no
matter how hard you work structural
racism is stopping you from any black
Americans and again I want to know who
these people are so we can offer them
scholarships and so we can make sure
they get into the schools they need to
get to who are who what are the
structures what are the structures this
is again suggesting that because history
has consequences everything today is bad
or inequality is equal to to inequity
and it's a lie and Michelle Obama knows
better than anybody it's a lie
when it comes to all those tiny stories
of hard work and self-determination that
we like to tell ourselves about America
well the reality is a lot more
complicated than that because for too
many people in this country no matter
how hard they work there are structural
barriers working against them that just
make the road longer and rockier and
sometimes it's almost impossible to move
upward at all at no point does she
suggest what these structural barriers
are or how we remove them the idea is no
matter how hard you work you're screwed
you think that might breed a little bit
of resentment and rage at the system and
by the way justify tearing down all the
institutions of the society as we will
see that is the actual agenda it's in
and to watch people buy into this
wholesale in an attempt to appease folks
is really quite astonishing it's quite
astonishing and quite immoral we'll get
to that in just one second because it
really is incredible stuff first let us
talk about the fact that Father's Day is
coming up and that means it's time to
get your dad the gift he has been
craving I'm talking of course about
stage Omaha Steaks calm go to Omaha
Steaks that come they have a limited
time Father's Day offer enter a code
Shapiro into the search bar
save 55% on the gift dad will love okay
I know that a little because they
actually sent me some kosher stakes and
they are astonishingly good I mean they
aged these things they are just
delicious and juicy oh my god
for $79.99
here's what your gift will include when
you go to Omaha Steaks calm and enter
coach Shapiro into the search bar for
naturally mean top sirloin steaks hand
carved aged at least 21 days for
tenderness and flavor for premium
boneless chicken breasts for a gourmet
jumbo Franks and kielbasa sausages a
package of savory all meat meat all beef
meatballs for perfectly browned potatoes
au gratin for made from scratch caramel
apple tartlets and an Omaha Steaks
signature seasoning packet dad will get
all of this delicious food plus the free
pound of steak cut bacon that amazing
gift ready to be shipped straight to
dad's store in time for Father's Day for
$79.99 doesn't get better than that dad
is gonna be happy when he opens that box
let me tell you this Father's Day send
dad the gift he really wants the steak
go to Omaha Steaks com take Shapiro in
the search bar say 55 percent off when
you send the summer sizzle pack for
$79.99 and get free steak cut bacon with
your order that's the stuff that makes
me wish I didn't keep kosher don't wait
go to Omaha Steaks com type Shapiro in
the search bar to order the summer
sizzle pack for Father's Day today Omaha
Steaks cons have Shapiro in that search
bar for these special Father's Day deal
okay we're gonna get to the culmination
of this message in the America is
systemically racist people buying into
this because there's this bizarre notion
in in many American communities that if
you acquiesce to the message that
somehow all of this will go away and be
better this is the first step toward the
destruction of the institution's
understand that's what this is it is one
thing to hug protesters because you all
believe the police brutality is bad it
is another thing to kneel before
protesters because you're acknowledging
that America systemically racist that is
not the same thing one of those things
is quite good one of those things is
quite bad we'll get to that in just one
second first 20/20 has been an
unbelievably insane year how insane
Trump is impeached this year okay that's
how insane this is I mean the last year
has the last six months have taken 93
years 93 and we are not even close to
the election we are in June guys there's
still five months to the election the
leftist media isn't helping things one
but you need good coverage of these
issues cuz the media are lying to you
we're gonna get to the media in just a
little while on the show the media are
lying to you systematically
systematically it's unbelievable when
you can't get the real story you have to
go outside the media narrative and get
the facts if you're a political junkie
set on getting both sides of the story
get a readers pass today from daily
we're calm you'll get access to
exclusive op-eds from us your podcast
host as well as guest writers in depth
analysis from our daily we're reporters
on top of our regular breaking
this membership tier is already a
bargain at 3 bucks a month but if you
joined today get your first month for 99
cents which is a great great deal you
also get access to a mobile app you
receive push notifications for breaking
news and special content and you can
join the community of daily wire members
who are actively commenting on and
discussing our content content with each
other that is mobile ad free access to
all daily wearer's news exclusive op-eds
and more on our mobile app all for the
low price of one dollar best of all your
dollars are getting you the news you
need without the left to spin head on
over to daily where comet slash
subscribe and join today also I would
urge you go check out a copy pre-order a
copy of my new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps it is the
most relevant book in history maybe it
truly the entire book is about how the
letters a quest by a large group of
Americans I call them
disintegration Asst who want to destroy
our Comment philosophy history and
culture we're watching it in real time
happening right now the book is not just
an indictment of that it's an
exploration of that philosophy and it's
a rebuttal of that world view a full
rebuttal of that worldview why the
disintegration is wrong about American
history which is a story of triumph over
tragedy why they're wrong about American
culture which is the story of Rights
over-over demands and why the American
story is a history of philosophy of the
Declaration of Independence equal rights
under law in a deal in Alien Abul rights
pre-existing government and why the left
lies about all of this stuff the book is
really important I mean I truly feel
like I wake up every morning wishing the
book was already out it's coming out
July 21st you can go pre-order right now
over at amazon.com or anywhere books are
sold is called how to destroy America in
three easy steps go check it out you're
listening so the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so the nasty device have been
cruel narrative that America is
systemically racist and evil has now
been taken swallowed whole by a huge
number of people across the country
mainly I think a lot of these people
want to do a couple things one virtue
signal and want to show that they care
and the way to show you care is by just
agreeing right this is it this is how
people are acting is if I put a black
box on my Twitter page or on my
Instagram page I've shown that I'm a
virtuous person really what did you just
sign on to yeah ever even thought about
it or is it just more to express
sympathy and I think most people are
good hearted and they want to express
sympathy for people who feel outraged at
police brutality's and instances of
racism I'm all for that but that's that
the people who are promulgating the
message at the highest intellectual
level it is not just that they condemn
police brutality and racism it is that
they are inciting you and the entire
system and they want you to repent for
sins you have not committed and so you
see what I think are hideous images like
this police officers washing the feet of
black community leaders in North
Carolina what do these police officers
do are these police officers racist is
there evidence that they've done
something cruelly racist why are they
washing people's feet are they are they
penitent sinners
wait what and why is this being done on
the basis of race did they victimize
these particular people to atone for a
sin you did not commit is itself sinful
you cannot atone for sins that other
people committed without taking on
responsibility and that of course is the
end goal here because if you believe
that you're buying off
he woke Astana left by engaging in the
kneeling and the feet washing and the
ritual humiliation if you believe that
you are buying them off and suddenly
they are going to be like oh well you
know this person showed their sympathy
so I'll give them the benefit of the
doubt next time there's a racist
incident think again the next time
something bad happens in that community
which is I believe Cary North Carolina
the next time something bad happens in
that community the protesters will be
right at that front door asking for the
police chief said that is the first
thing that will happen
hey Democrats were kneeling in the in
the Congress today I mean they were all
wearing it looks like some sort of scarf
I assume too to symbol to
african-americans cuz I think there's a
cultural scarf I don't know but here
they are all kneeling for America
kneeling kneeling for America's history
truly incredible stuff and truly
ridiculous stuff
because if the idea is that you have to
kneel to the notion that America is
systemically evil that colin kaepernick
was right after all that the american
flag represents racism and bigotry it
doesn't represent freedom in Liberty
then what the hell are you doing in the
United States Congress why do you
believe the institutions that you serve
are good shouldn't you want to tear down
all those institutions and the demands
will never end if you think the demands
end with just a little bit of virtue
signaling online you've bought your way
out Amazon by putting the
blacklivesmatter thing on your on your
page now everybody's gonna be happy with
you think again the New York Times put
out an op-ed over the weekend that
literally says that you should text your
relatives and loved ones is a direct
quote telling them you will not be
visiting them or answering phone calls
until they take significant action in
supporting black lives either through
protests or financial contributions so
you're gonna tell mom and dad I'm not
visiting unless you sign a check to my
preferred organization how delightful
perhaps we can have reporting squads
that'd be good perhaps we can have you
know people who report their parents if
they to to to the social media squad in
order to in order to shame them I think
that'd be great NBC MSNBC C's Ali Velshi
he says you might you might think you're
not racist and you might be right you
might not be racist but that's not good
enough right now I have a question why
is that not good enough why is it not
good enough to just oppose racism and
think racism is bad why is it that I
have to math whatever platitudes you
decide to put out there today including
a platitude that is not a platitude at
all but an extraordinarily nasty
proposition that Americans are deeply
racist but they are systemically biased
that the American system is racist
through and through no it seems to me
that you know what basic human decency
requires of you to be basically human
and decent that's it it doesn't require
you to Mao the crap that Ali Velshi
wants you to mouth here is Ali Velshi on
MSNBC well if you think you're not
racist you could be right but in this
day and age that's simply not good
enough up next why it's time to check
our bias at the door and leaned into the
discomfort that is necessary for real
change what discomfort are you talking
about
seriously what's his comfort if you want
to cite something that I have done wrong
I'm happy to talk to you about it if you
want to talk about inciting a broad
American system or suggesting that I'm
keeping my knee on the neck of black
America is how Sharpton has suggested an
F off because I'm not and neither are
you
I would assume the
this is insanity it's insanity and it
has consequences because once you
suggest the American system is
completely disgusting top to bottom and
all the institutions of America becomes
simply symbols of the deep-seated
American racism that is it becomes
symbols of this deeply corrupt system
it's not enough for my pens to simply
say we stand with George Floyd's family
which is something he said he has to say
that America is corrupt
through and through it's not good enough
for pens to say what everybody agrees
with the police brutality is bad we
don't want to see any instances of it
Pence is still a bad man here is pence
over the weekend of George Floyd was a
tragedy and president Trump's made it
clear justice will be served we know now
charges have been brought against all
four police officers and President
immediately deployed Justice Department
officials to examine the possibility of
federal charges to be brought as well
but what happened on that street in
Minneapolis shocked the conscience of
the nation and we stand with every
Americans taken aback by that act and we
will stand for justice every good enough
right but beg Pence is racist cuz not
good enough according to Ali Velshi not
not enough to oppose brutal killings not
enough instead you have to suggest that
actually everything's great and this is
the new tic and the new tack it's
amazing it's amazing so there are those
of us where like okay well now that
you're suggesting with the entire
American institutional infrastructure is
bad tearing it down might have some
really bad consequences in fact if I
wanted to point to tearing down American
institutions having bad consequences I
might point to the fact that there were
a bunch of people out there who are
justifying rioting and looting right
over the past week and that was shut
down nearly every major American city
for a week so people could riot and loot
to their heart's content and then it
really sucked
it was quite terrible I might point that
out so instead what we get are MoMA
ridiculous people in the media and in
our politics suggesting that this never
happened it's a figment of your
imagination if you're worried about
America being mugged by reality cuz
here's the here is the reality the
reality is America is not systemic ly
racist America is free America is good
America has a law enforcement body that
overwhelmingly is ensuring that you can
live a free and prosperous life once you
tear away that stuff you
mugged by reality so instead what we're
gonna get is people basically declaring
that they're just not going to accept
that reality exists reality just doesn't
exist okay here is a little bit of video
from what Minneapolis looked like in the
aftermath of the rioting and looting
it's a war zone
things are on fire the buildings have
been completely burned out okay that's
what it looks like I drove around Los
Angeles like nice areas of Los Angeles
all the windows were boarded up over the
weekend but good news
CBC Congressional Black Caucus chair
Karen basses protesting has been
peaceful every single day across the
country it's been peaceful every single
day okay now let me just put it this way
if the anti lockdown protest had burned
a building it would have been violent
protests across the country right that
would been the headline but when riding
and looting shuts down every major
American city for a week then all we get
is that everything is peaceful now again
I don't think the protesters are the
riders and looters but I also think it's
absurd Zweig nor the rioting and the
looting
that's absurd but that's what Karen bass
is doing I think we're in a real moment
in our country the passion that the
people are displaying I'm so glad now
that the protesting is peaceful it's
been every day it's been across the
country I think that it is going to lay
the basis for the momentum for us to
bring about the change that we need to
do and not only that if you're a white
liberal right you have to understand and
if you oppose crime if you want to
preserve any institutions of American
society that's coming from a place of
privilege so over the weekend the
Minneapolis City Council vowed to defund
the police to defund it to get rid of it
they want to call it police a police
free city so not even what Camden New
Jersey did where they they kind of lied
about it they said we're gonna abolish
the police and then they brought in the
staties and actually doubled the number
of officers on the street they just got
rid of the police union and they ended
around it they basically created a
charter school police force right that's
all they did in in Minneapolis they talk
about absolutely just getting rid of the
police entirely okay so there's a woman
that named bender appropriately named
because she's on a bender here who is
who was on CNN from the Minneapolis City
Council and she was asked a very obvious
question by Allison cammarata well what
happens when somebody commits a crime
what are you into the police now
remember you abolish to the police
because the police are systemically
racist because America is systemically
racist so the answer here follows once
you say that America is systemically
racist and if the police are
systemic ly racist and that the police
doing their job is just an extension of
the evil past of policing in the United
States you come to the point where crime
is good okay and this is exactly what a
Minneapolis City Council member said on
Alison Cammarata day this is this says
it all
if the America is about to be mugged by
reality so hard it's gonna make our head
swim listen this clip is just
mind-boggling what if in the middle of
the night my home is broken into who do
I call yes I mean I hear that loud and
clear from a lot of my neighbors and I
know and myself too and I know that that
comes from a place of privilege because
for those of us for whom the system is
working I think we need to step back and
imagine what it would feel like to
already live in that reality we're
calling the police may mean more harm is
done if you're worried about a crime
being committed against you it's coming
from a place of privilege now let's just
be real about this the vast majority of
crime victims in minority neighborhoods
are members of minority communities
they're the ones calling the cops you
actually need more policing in these
areas high crime communities require
more police not fewer police and in fact
if you want to explain a disparity
here's a way to explain a disparity
through discrimination one of the
reasons you have high crime that that
ravaged black communities since the turn
of the 20th century I mean murder rates
that are a multiple of the white murder
rates is because white communities
deliberately decided to withdraw police
from those areas and said you're on your
own you wanna know why gang warfare
became a prominent feature of urban life
inner city life because the police were
not there but here she is saying check
your priveledge if you're worried about
crime that's elisa bender the president
of the Minneapolis City Council this is
that's what you got you're gonna be
mugged by reality you tear down the
institutions of American life you can't
expect to keep all the good stuff
but that is exactly what people are
expecting okay so this is the new
campaign the new campaign is defund the
police so over the weekend the
Washington DC mayor decided that she'd
be making a real statement by painting
on the street black lives matter in
giant yellow letters all across the
street Wow racism solved lady you really
did it you've done it now all the black
victims of crime in Washington DC of
whom there are a disproportionate number
it's all it's all solved guys the police
were the problem all along all along the
police were the problem
known who could have known so she
painted black lives matter across the
street and again the only reason that I
object to the black lives matter
sloganeering is not because I don't
believe black lives matter it's because
I do believe lack lives matter just as I
would object to some but some mayor
painting across the across the street
science is real yes I agree science is
real the implication of you painting
something like that is that you believe
that everyone who disagrees with you
doesn't think science is real right the
whole idea of the black lives matter
slogan is that they don't want it to be
unifying many of the leaders of the
movement look at their agenda it is not
a unifying agenda it is abolishing the
police it is free Palestine it is
abolish income inequality through
massive redistribution programs and
property seizures all this is on the BLM
website okay the idea of black lives
matter is that there is a vast swath of
Americans who disagree with you because
they don't believe black lives matter
and that I find insulting okay so anyway
she painted black lives matter on the
street Mayor Bowser in Washington DC so
BLM just did the natural thing they said
well what does that mean what does that
mean they took the natural next step and
they painted equals defund the police
they painted this on the street in
Washington DC
well now the agenda is clear and it
follows once America is deeply and
systemically racist and evil then
obviously you should defund the police
that's where they painted it on the
street in Washington DC defund the
police genius hey that's not the worst
of it over in Minneapolis where they
burned down a police precinct and had a
week of rioting and looting and people
were hurt and businesses were ravaged
and the city was basically set on fire
the mayor of Minneapolis who started
this whole thing off by suggesting that
white privilege was responsible for the
death of George George Floyd that was a
racist killing who's going on TV and
said he's gonna check his own white
privilege and all this you know what you
want the proof that the kneeling is will
get you nowhere this is this is proof
positive so the mayor of Minneapolis he
went out there with a black lives matter
crowd and he begged forgiveness right he
he suggested that he was checking his
own privilege and then they asked him
are you willing to abolish the police
and he said no and they told him to get
the F out and started chanting at him
shame shame shame okay so
premise the conclusion follows the
premise once you suggest that all the
institutions are racist
this guy's member the institution Jakob
Frey hey here here is the here's the
clip it's pretty incredible no matter
how low he bends the knee that knee will
never be bent low enough for four people
who decide that America is systemically
evil jacob frye we have it yes or no
question for you
yes or no who user makes debugging
Minneapolis Lisa party
we don't want no puppies back
I mean pretty obvious with the agenda
and they're saying the agenda we don't
want no more police okay let's just be
clear about this if the police would
draw from minority communities the
people who are gonna pay the most for
that or minority communities a lot of
black people will die if the police are
thrown from minority communities and
don't give me again Camden New Jersey
again they didn't get rid of the police
they doubled the number of police on the
streets they just called them County
police as opposed to city police that is
not what they're talking about in
Minneapolis they literally put out a
proposal talking about how they wanted
streets free of police you know what
that means it means criminals have rain
the leftist attempt to reach utopia
through the following chain of events
we'll see if it works man it's a bold
strategy cotton we'll see how it pays
off for him here's the strategy you
should have a gun only law enforcement
should have a gun sanctuary cities
illegal immigrants should should be able
to come in your city with no sort of
consequence and you can't report it to
the federal government
homelessness should be able to run
roughshod across your cities we
shouldn't able to do anything about that
also abolish the police how you think
that's gonna go seriously how do you
think it's gonna go I mean the the
reality in America's major cities is
going to be there gonna be a trashy
there gonna be a trashy and you're
seeing it this is not just in
Minneapolis I first of all you have el
hand Omar who whatever she says do the
opposite you'll have a successful life
Ilhan Omar the representative from
Minnesota she was out there saying she
wants to defund the police which again
the people who are most harmed by the
said the people who are most victimized
by crime the people who need the police
most will be the people who are harmed
the most when the police go a way and
also very convenient for a lot of the
people who are shouting defund the
police in the media particularly because
they all have private security it's
pretty easy to be well you want to talk
about white privilege white privilege or
privilege more generally is saying get
rid of the publicly funded police
because I'm rich enough that I already
have my own private security firm yet
Omar has protection from congressional
police here Zohan Omar never stopped
saying not only do we need to this
invest for in police but we need to
completely dismantle
Minneapolis Police Department the
Minneapolis Police Department is rotten
to the roots and so when we dismantle it
we get rid of that cancer and we allow
for something beautiful to rise and that
reimagining allows us to figure out what
Public Safety looks like for us the
something beautiful that's gonna be
rising is going to be the number of
arsons and robberies and murders that's
what's going to be the beautiful thing
that rises when you get rid of the
police guess what
yeah what's amazing is that we're doing
this within days of Minneapolis being
burned we're doing defund the police
within days of Minneapolis being burned
and complete public disorder and people
have defied the police is the message
you took away from this were you dropped
on your head as a child but again all of
this makes sense if you believe that the
police are just the enforcement arm of
an evil system that's the real message
here Bill DeBlasio is doing the same
thing in New York he wants city fund the
cops in New York City where by the way
300 police officers were injured in the
George Floyd protests protests rioting
and looting is more liking is more like
it you don't get to call yourself a
protester if you injure a cop here is
Bill DeBlasio talking about defunding
the cops in New York when I turn to our
task force and said what should we do
and we talked over these last few days
we had a series of meetings the task
force said it was important to address
on a budget level the need to focus more
on our young people the need to make a
clear statement that our investments in
our young people are our future
policing matters for sure but the
investments in our youth are
foundational Amazings he's gonna cut the
funding from the from the NYPD in the
aftermath of this in LA they're doing
the same thing Mayor Eric Garcetti our
garbage mayor here in Los Angeles he has
suggested that he wants to defund the
police in Los Angeles he wants to cut
150 million dollars from the police
budget it's already an understaffed
police again I have friends in the LAPD
they are wildly understaffed so this was
the natural consequence a City
Councilman and Monica Rodriguez showed
up to lecture the LAPD and the LAPD
officers they were having none of it
they're like we're here and we haven't
done like if you have an instance of
racism then bring it to our police union
prosecute us but you got nothing here
and here you are saying that we should
we're the only thing
stopping the looters and the riders were
the only thing standing between Melrose
Avenue being burned to the ground and
Rodeo Drive being destroyed and and
people who want to do that
and here you aren't trying to cut our
funding here is the LAPD just slamming
the City Councilwoman frack in their
school is because of them because in a
constant pandering at the Police
Commission it's 100 of them but you guys
are listen to them what about the
law-abiding citizens that are lower body
they don't break them all all they want
is these officers to protect them if
this is what they do every day and now
you're cutting from these from their
families
that's a black police representative by
the way who's going out for the City
Council woman but don't worry AOC is
here to fix all of it
AOC also agrees we should defund the
police and one teos he says it the font
of all wisdom here is AOC saying defund
the police again she's never gonna have
to pay for the consequence of this she's
living in her cush congressional
apartment in a nice area of Washington
DC here she is pushing defund the police
the same budgetary in justices now
Martin Luther King he said but just are
moral documents they show what our
priorities and commitments are as a
nation and as a society and the same
problems that we are seeing the same
problems that we are seeing on a city
council level and on a city level which
are you have an entire city budget and
half of that budget goes to policing and
a shred to education a shred to mental
health services a crumb for hospitals
that is mirrored on the federal level
okay what she's saying is not even close
to Toronto factual level the huge
percentage budgets in the cities are not
going to police I mean it's just that
that's an astonishing lie but beyond
that again the defund the police moving
in the aftermath of widespread rioting
and looting you can only justify that if
you think the rioting and the looting in
the crime are okay and that any attempt
to tamp those things down is an attempt
to
shore up the institutions of white
privilege I do not believe that
America's institutions are fundamentally
racist that does not mean that America's
history has not been filled with endemic
racism it doesn't mean that today the
institutions are not racist I do not
believe that America's philosophy
culture history are the story of racism
and I am NOT I'm never going to kneel to
the idea that America will be healed or
unified by trashing the American system
entirely in favor of defund the police
by the way where's Joe Biden on this how
does Joe Biden feel about funding the
police love to hear that answer all
right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content we
didn't even get to the New York Times
which fire to top that editor for
displeasing its woke staffers we'll get
to that a little bit later with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Hoss directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director pavel
wide aus key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by mike camino hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you